WEAPONS OF INTELLIGENCE AGAINST
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, LIKE WE'VE
BEEN EXPOSING ON THIS PROGRAM.
JOINING US NOW, NRA TV COUNTRY
PETER DAN BONGINO.
DANIEL HOFFMAN.
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA.
WE WILL START WITH YOU.
DANIEL HOFFMAN.
I INTERVIEWED JOSE RODRIGUEZ, HE
WAS THERE.
I DON'T LIKE HEARING THE TAPE
ANYMORE BECAUSE I AIRED AT THE
LAST TWO NIGHTS MY LOOK
SKINNIER.
HE WAS THERE, THE INFORMATION
THAT LED TO THE COURIER THAT LED
TO BIN LADEN CAME FROM THAT
ENHANCED INTERROGATION.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN
BIN LADEN WITHOUT THOSE
TECHNIQUES WHICH WERE MEDICALLY
SUPERVISED AT THE HIGHEST DEGREE
OF SAFETY, ALTHOUGH THEY DIDN'T
KNOW IT.
>> WRIGHT, SEAN.
THERE'S A COUPLE POINTS HERE I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S AN
UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTH FOR THOSE
WHO DIDN'T SUPPORT THE PROGRAM
AND DON'T TODAY.
THAT YES, IT ACTUALLY DID WORK.
YOU CAN DEBATE THE MORALS AND
ETHICS OF THE PROGRAM BUT IT DID
WORK.
WE DID OBTAIN SIGNIFICANCE
INTELLIGENCE NOT JUST ON FINDING
BIN LADEN BUT OTHER AL QAEDA
OPERATIVES AS WELL AS WE STOP
THREATS AGAINST OUR NATION.
COULD YOU IMAGINE IF WE HAD
THESE TECHNIQUES AND THEY WERE
APPROVED AND WE HAD SOMEONE IN
DETENTION WHO KNEW ABOUT A
THREAT AND AN ATTACK TOOK PLACE
ON AFTERWARDS, POSTMORTEM, WE
WERE ASKED IF WE DID ALL WE
COULD AND USED ALL OF OUR
CAPABILITIES AND WE REPLY THAT
WE DID NOT.
I THINK THOSE SAME CONGRESSMEN
WHO ARE GRILLING GINA HASPEL
WOULD HAVE CONFRONTED US OVER
DERELICTION OF DUTY.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO
DR. GORKA.
DR. GORKA, THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES FACING THE
COUNTRY AND LOOK, IT WAS THE LOT
THE TIME.
ALSO IT WAS UNDER THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF MEDICAL SUPERVISION.
WE ARE NOT, SOME OF THESE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS SUGGEST, WE
ARE NOT THE ENEMY.
NOW, THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE KNOWN
IT WAS MEDICALLY SUPERVISED, BUT
THEY DIDN'T NEED TO KNOW THAT.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF 3,000
AMERICANS KILLED, WE NEEDED
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT ELSE
MIGHT BE COMING, WHAT DANGERS
EXIST, AND I THINK SHE AND
OTHERS DID AMERICA A GREAT
SERVICE HERE.
>> THIS WOMAN IS A PATRIOT AND A
30-YEAR PLUS VETERAN OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
PERSONALLY, AND I'M NOT GOING TO
GO INTO THE DETAILS, I HAVE SOME
ISSUES WITH ENHANCED
INTERROGATION BECAUSE OF THE
DANGER IT CAN LEAD TO A PEOPLE
FABRICATING INFORMATION TO GET
YOU TO STOP DOING WHAT YOU ARE
DOING TO THEM.
BUT LOOK AT THE FACTS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THREE
PEOPLE, SEAN.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
INTERROGATIONS THAT LED TO THE
SAVING OF LIVES UNDOUBTEDLY.
AND THE LAST POINT IS ONE OF
HONOR.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WERE FINE
WITH THESE TECHNIQUES, AND ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE WERE FINE WITH
THIS WOMAN WHEN SHE WAS ACTING
DIRECTOR I NEVER QUESTIONED HER
INTEGRITY OR HER MORALS.
AND THAT IS DESPICABLE THAT
THESE COWARDS NOW ARE ATTACKING
HER FOR EXACTLY THE THINGS THEY
APPROVED OF AFTER 9/11.
>> Sean: WELL SAID.
DAN BONGINO, LET ME TURN TO
OTHER TOPICS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOWED MILITARY
FORCE AFTER MISSILES WERE FIRED
OVER JAPAN AND THREATS TO GUAM
AND EVEN THE CONTINENTAL U.S.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT SANCTIONS ON
NORTH KOREA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MOCKED THE
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR.
THE MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS SAID HE
WOULD START A NUCLEAR WAR.
WHAT IF WE HAD SO FAR?
WE'VE HAD CONCESSIONS.
THREE AMERICANS HOME SAFELY
TODAY.
WE NEVER THOUGHT WE WOULD SEE
KIM JONG UN CROSS THE DMZ INTO
THE ARMS OF THE SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT.
WE SEE NOW THE POSSIBILITY OF
THE DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
KOREAN PENINSULA IN TOTAL.
WE HAVE SEEN OTHER CONCESSIONS.
THIS IS AN AMAZING TEACHABLE
MOMENT FOR PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH, IS IT NOT?
>> IT IS, BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL GET ZERO CREDIT BECAUSE
THE, YOU KNOW, I'VE GOT TO BE
CAREFUL.
I GET REALLY UPSET, SEAN,
BECAUSE THE THINK TANK PEOPLE
AND THE SWAMP RATS, THE SLOBS
WHO HAVE BEEN IN POWER FOREVER
WHO FOLLOW THE STRUCTURED PATHS
OF FORMAL DIPLOMACY.
THEY HAVE HAD THEIR BOW TIES ON.
THEY'VE HAD THEIR COCKTAIL
LUNCHES.
THEY ARE THE ONES LAUGHING AT
TRUMP RIGHT NOW DESPITE THE FACT
THAT HE'S GOT RESULTS THAT NONE
OF THEM COULD GET.
THEY THINK HE'S SOME KIND OF
NEANDERTHAL CREEP.
THEY FOLLOWED ALL THE FORMAL
PATHS, PLAYED BY ALL THE RULES.
YOU KNOW WHAT PROMPTED?
HE CAME IN THERE.
HE WASN'T USED TO THESE RULES.
HE WAS A BUILDER FROM QUEENS AND
HE SAID WAIT.
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT, THERE
ARE STILL NUKES ON THE PENINSULA
DESPITE THE SMART PEOPLE TELLING
US HOW TO GET RID OF IT.
HE WAS UNPREDICTABLE, AND HE'S
THE ONE WHO GOT RESULTS, AND HE
WON'T GET AN OUNCE OF CREDIT FOR
IT AMONGST THAT CLASS.
>> Sean: AS HE SAID, HE JUST
WANTS TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM WHICH
BY THE WAY I REMEMBER
WINSTON CHURCHILL SAID BLOOD,
TOIL, TEARS, SWEAT, VICTORY.
THAT'S OUR GOAL.
THE PRESIDENT THEY SAID I WANT
THE WORLD SAFER.
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE ISRAELIS.
DANIEL HOFFMAN, THEY HAD TO
STRIKE BACK.
YOU CANNOT ALLOW THE IRANIAN
FORCES AND MULLAHS TO FIRE
MISSILES FROM SYRIA BASES INTO
ISRAEL AND NOT HAVE A MASSIVE
PRICE TO PAY.
>> THE VIEWERS WILL RECALL THAT
NO MATTER WHAT THREAT, WHETHER
IT'S AN IRAQI NUCLEAR PROGRAM IN
THE 1980s OR A SYRIAN NUCLEAR
PROGRAM WHICH ISRAEL DESTROYED
IN 2007, THEY DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
THE THREATS OFF THE TABLE.
THEY HAVE IT EXCEPTIONALLY
STRONG INTELLIGENCE CAPABILITIES
IN THIS CASE THE IRANIANS
PRESENTED AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT
TO THEM FROM SYRIA.
FRANKLY, SEAN, EXPECT ISRAEL TO
CONTINUE TO MOUNT THOSE SORTS OF
OPERATIONS TO GET THERE IS A
DISTANCE A.
>> Sean: LET'S SAY A STEP
FURTHER.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT, WILL BY
WITHDRAWING FROM THIS HORRIFIC
$150 BILLION IDIOCY OF BARACK
OBAMA, DR. GORKA, SHOWING THE
WORLD AMERICA IS BACK.
AMERICA'S LEADING OF THE WORLD
STAGE.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT MESSAGE
I THINK TO SEND THE WORLD,
WHETHER OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES LIKE
IT OR NOT, I FRANKLY DON'T CARE.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO TOW THE
LINE.
THEY WILL MOAN AND MOAN BUT THEY
WILL FOLLOW OUR LEAD BECAUSE WE
ARE THE ONLY LEADERS OUT THERE.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS IN THE 20TH
CENTURY AND THAT'S HOW IT'S
GOING TO WORK UNDER DONALD TRUMP
IN THE 21ST CENTURY.
THAT'S POWER, POLITICS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS VERY SIMPLE.